[indistinct radio chatter]
Ruston: The large earthquake
in Pakistan in 2013
was the first time
I heard about a big earthquake.
[dramatic music]
I was so shocked by
the number of people affected,
and I just really wanted
to help.
[mellow music]
I started app development
when I was 17,
which was before I studied
at university.
I realized my skill
of developing apps
would really help,
so I decided to make
My Earthquake Alerts,
which distribute information
about an earthquake
much faster
than any other source.
Every second counts.
when it comes to an earthquake
Some say that the app
has saved their lives,
and they've been able
to get in touch
with family members quickly.
It's amazing that
you really can build something
to help
a large number of people
from anywhere in the world.
From a city or from
a very rural place like this.
[music continues]
Chidera:
Growing up in Nigeria,
my friends and I found
preparing for exams
to be boring
and not very efficient,
so I decided to do an app
that helps students
prepare for exams
in a fun and personalized way.
PrepUp is different from
the traditional study methods.
It's a game for learning.
Also,
you get personalized lessons
that are tailored
to individual students.
Nweke: Using PrepUp
was like playing a game.
It made things
far easier for me.
I did well on the exams,
and I got 264.
That's a pretty high score.
Chidera: I feel really good
creating a product
that people use every day
and it's helpful to them.
Currently, we've helped over
120,000 students across Africa.
We couldn't have done this
without the reach
of the Android platform.
[music continues]
Chen:
Ari, do we have any basil?
Ari: A little bit.
Chen: Can you pick me
a little bit?
I grew up in a loving
and supportive household
that sometimes had trouble
putting food on the table,
so we've always been aware
of thinking about
how to set a budget and how
to really make things stretch.
There are 42 million Americans
who are on food stamps
right now,
and most of them have
smartphones
and use the Internet.
Our app, FreshEBT,
helps people who receive
food stamp benefits
in the United States
manage their balance
and to become
more financially healthy.
It also helps people find
grocery recipes and new jobs.
It means a lot to us as a team
that we are actually meeting
real user needs
through the app.
man: Hi.
woman: How you doing?
man: Good. How you doing?
woman: Good.
Thank you.
Chen: And that's one of the
things that's most rewarding
about the work that we do is,
we get to see the daily impact
of building a product
that really meets the needs
of those
who are really seeking help.
[gentle music]
Pi: Forest is an app
that help user to stay focused
on what's more important
in their life.
People will put down
their phones for a while
and wait for the tree
to grow up.
Each virtual tree
in the Forest app
represent focused time
for the user.
Yu: After the app was released,
we got some user feedback
about if they can
plant real trees in the app,
and that's when we found
Trees for Future.
[music continues]
Trees for Future
is a nonprofit organization,
and they plant trees on Earth.
They also help
the local farmers
to plan
different type of crops
so that they can
feed their families better
and have better lives.
We've came to Kenya today
for the first time
to visit Trees of Future
and the farmers and farms.
man: This one,
we call it pod tree.
Yu: It's amazing that a simple
app can achieve such things
and bring positive impact
to society
thanks to all of our users.
[music continues]